we already know that two to the fourth
power can be viewed as starting with a 1
and then multiplying it by 2 4 times so
let me do that so times 2 times 2 times
2 times 2 and that will give us let's
see 2 times 2 is 4 8 16 so that will
give us 16 now I will ask you a more
interesting question what do you think 2
to the negative negative 4 powers and I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about that well you might be
tempted to say oh well maybe it's
negative 16 or something like that but
remember what the exponent operation is
trying to do this is one way of viewing
it is this is telling us how many times
are we going to multiply 2 times
negative 1 but here we're gonna we're
gonna multiply negative 4 times what
what is negative
traditionally me negative traditionally
means the opposite so here this is how
many times you're going to multiply
maybe when we make it negative this says
how many times we're gonna start it with
a 1 how many times are we going to
divide by 2 so let's think about that a
little bit so this could be viewed as 1
times and we're going to divide by 2 4
times Well dividing by 2 is the same
thing as multiplying by 1/2 so we could
say that this is 1 times 1/2 times 2 me
student 1 colors can take so 1 times 1/2
times 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 notice
multiplying by 1/2 4 times is the exact
same thing as dividing by 2 4 times and
in this situation this would get you a
1/2 well 1 times 1/2 is just 1/2 times
1/2 is 1/4 times 1/2 is 1 8 times 1/2 is
1 over 16 and so you probably see the
relationship here if you're this is
essentially you're starting with the one
you're dividing by 2 4 times you could
also say you could also say that 2 - I'm
gonna do the same colors 2 to the
negative 4 2 to the negative 4 is the
same thing as 1 Oh
for two to the fourth power one over two
to the fourth power let me color code it
nicely so you realize what the negative
is doing so this is negative right over
here let me do that in a better color
other than magenta something that jumps
out so this negative right over here
this is what's causing us to go one over
so two to the negative four is the same
thing based on the way we've defined it
just up right here as one over the order
is the reciprocal of 2 to the fourth or
1 over 2 to the fourth and so you could
view this as being 1 over 2 times so 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 if you just do 2
to the fourth as taking 4 2s and
multiplying them or if you use this idea
right over here you could view it as
starting with a 1 and multiplying it by
2 4 times either way you are going to
get 1 over 1 over 16 1 over 16 so let's
do a few more examples of this just so
that we make sure things are clear to us
so let's try let's try 3 to the negative
third power so remember whenever you see
that negative what my brain always does
is say I need to take the reciprocal
here so this is going to be equal to I'm
gonna highlight the negative again this
is going to be 1 over 3 to the third
power 1 over 3 to the third power which
would be equal to well 1 over 3 times 3
or you could say 1 over 3 times 3 times
3 or 1 times 3 times 3 times 3 is going
to be 27 so this is going to be 127th
let's try another example I'll do 2 or 3
more so let's take let's take a negative
number to a negative exponent just to
see if we can confuse ourselves so let's
take the number negative 4 negative 4
and let's take it I don't want my
numbers to get too big too fast so let's
take so let's just take negative 2
let's take negative 2 and let's take it
to the negative 3 power negative I want
to make my negatives in magenta negative
3 power
negative
negative three power so at first this
might be daunting do the negatives
cancel and that will just be the
remnants is in your brain that they're
trying to think of multiplying negatives
do not apply that here remember you see
a negative exponent that just means the
reciprocal of the positive exponent so 1
over negative 2 negative 2 to the third
power so the positive third power and
this is equal to this is equal to 1 over
negative 2 negative 2 times negative 2
times negative 2 times negative 2 or you
could view it as 1 times negative 2
times negative 2 times negative 2 which
is going to give you 1 over negative 8
or negative negative 1 eighths let me
scroll over a little bit I don't want to
have to start squinching things so this
is equal to negative 1/8 let's do one
more example just in an attempt to
confuse ourselves let's take let's take
I don't know
let's take 5/8 and raise this to the
negative negative 2 power negative 2
power so once again this negative way I
got a fraction is a negative here
remember this just means 1 over 5/8 to
the 2nd power so this is just going to
be the same thing as 1 over five eighths
1 over 5/8 squared 1 over 5/8 squared
which is going to be the same thing
which is going to be the same thing so
this is going to be equal to trying to
color-code it 1 over 5/8 times 5/8 which
is 25 over 60 25 over 64 1 over 25 over
64 is just going to be 64 over 25
so one another way to think about it is
you're going to take the reciprocal of
this and raise it and raise it to the
positive exponent so another way you
could have thought about this another
way you could have thought about this is
5/8 to the negative 2 power I'm
just take the reciprocal of this eight
fish and raise it to the positive to
power so all of these statements are
equivalent and that would have applied
even when you are dealing with non
fractions as your base right over here
so too you could say well this is going
to be the same thing two to the negative
four is going to be the same thing as
taking my reciprocal so this is going to
be the same thing as taking the
reciprocal of 2 which is which is 1 over
2 and raising it to the positive to the
positive 4 power